and thank you
to the organizers for inviting me
so i changed my thoughts as fast
yesterday that
this topic would be more
interesting to this audience as opposed
to my whole clustering
and it's also the first time i've
presented this uh
this paper that's from actually a while
back that i wouldn't do it although then
i think it would be more interesting to
this audience
so
okay so the title says what's going to
pass but i'm going to give you a very
short introduction on why the tv
constantly matters and
there are many reasons why myers and the
one i know a little more about is
clustering
or graph partitioning and
so
this is the setting actually
we were interested at our time and and
now
more interesting graph partitioning in
other settings like network
analysis but anyway
set points in space
and we want to uh to look at the
observations x1 through xn and we want
to partition them into k groups
and we want the group to be discussed we
want the groups to be
similar and in
the group to be dissimilar
and there are many techniques
the graphical ones
the classical ones here
and
heuristics um to be the the state of the
art right now in a number of areas
okay
so uh
let's have all the points id from uh
some subset of rp
okay so rd is the ambient space in the
dimension unnecessary large here could
be two or three
and
we're going to
so those partitioning heuristics applied
to graphs and here we have a set of
points so we build a graph on a set of
points
most of that should be standard for most
of you
we have
a former graph in the uh so the index
set is one through n this is what
indexes the observations
and
the glass can type can have weights in
general
okay so
how do you put the edges in
how you choose edges yeah so i'm going
to explain so three ways of doing it
that are very very common in
in the literature the first one is the
epsilon vowel graph so you uh put an
edge between two points at a within
distance epsilon
and another one is a k-nearest neighbor
graph where you put a mesh between two
points if uh so there are two
versions of that let's say one of them
would be if one of them is among the
k-nearest neighbors of the other one
and the third and then you can have also
um
the case where the graph is really
connected where you have weights
um
that decrease as a function of the
distance between the two points okay so
that is very classical
okay what's the motivation for that form
of the weight
in the last one this one right here
so
misha will talk more about this but uh
essentially like this connects nicely to
the
laplacian on the on the manifold
so this will be a discrete
because you're the only one
it was off um because here you look at
points so it's a it's it's on the graph
right but it would so misha's work
with the parthenon he has been on
proving that he has some sort of
convergence to from the graph
laplacian photograph
um yeah graph retention to the uh
laplacian on the manifold if the samples
are if the samples are from a manifold
or domain
of rd
okay
okay so let's let's consider the the
situation where we want to partition the
graph into
uh two
sets
so we're looking at by partition
and we've seen that several times this
week that's what prompted me to actually
uh go over this work
um so the way uh we chose to do it is uh
so the different ways of defining in
particular the uh
well either you count edges or you sum
the weights and um
anyway so this would be this is the
discrete uh perimeter
so it's the the weight so some of the
weights between uh
a node in s and a node in uh as
complement
and the volume of a set s is simply the
sum of the degrees in that uh set okay
or some of the weights in in general in
that set
sorry this would be volume sorry about
that this will involve
okay and the normalized cut is simply uh
well there are different ways of
defining it
and this i think is the one that
defines the trigger constant so you have
the discrete parameter on top and then
here you have the minimum between the
volumes of s or the volume of s
complement then you try to minimize
this
uh
over all subsets of nodes
okay
so the
the value of this optimization problem
is what's called the trigger constant of
the graph g
okay so
anyway the different names for uh
trigger constant is you know it appears
in many areas in random walks for
example on graphs and so on um
okay and uh so you know intuitively we
want to minimize so
we want to partition the graph so that
we have
a few edges between where they have not
much weight between the two
the two pieces of the partition
and but we're protecting ourselves
against uh very small sets
by dividing by the volume in there okay
so if the volume is very small then uh
it's possible that you want that that
won't minimize the
normalized cut
okay
okay so all that is complete and and uh
optimize this optimization problem is uh
is hard
anyway so people um you know so you know
i'm going to talk about heuristic anyway
here is a picture example so
in this particular case the set m is
going to is the union of two disks as
you can see pretty much 300 points and
this is a neighborhood graph on the
points i don't remember this actually my
collaborator bruno peltier
actually i forgot to say that
this is john's work with bueno peltier
and pia pillow both in france
and um
this is one of the either kenya's
neighbor or epsilon ball graph i don't
know which one
okay so you know essentially we like to
cut where uh the blue the dashed line is
and uh you know how can we achieve that
so
anyway so this is this is not to talk
about how to achieve this but uh this is
a motivation for now okay
and here is the uh the spectral
heuristic or uh relaxation uh to this
problem so you define the degree matrix
uh and uh
and then
subsequently you define the the
normalized graph laplace actually is not
correct it should be a d one d minus one
half dimension i have here sorry about
that
and um
so the
there's an algorithm uh
graph bisection graph respectively or
spectrograph partitioning
and
this this paper has been mentioned a few
times in this conference and it's not
really the first one proposing this but
anyway
i'm not an expert in the literature
there
so the idea is to look at the second
non-trivial uh eigenvector so the first
one so again this is not the correct one
but it should be minus one half minus
one half here
uh this laplacian has again back has
eigenvalue zero mean the multiplicity of
the number of connect components in the
graph and the second smallest uh
eigenvalue is non-zero if the graph is
connected which we're going to assume
here
and
so we look at the second eigenvector so
the the eigenvector corresponding to the
second smallest eigenvalue
and the partition so now we have uh we
look at uh
the so essentially we use that second
eigenvector to embed the uh
the nodes of the graph in the line okay
and then we try to find a um
a good
partition and then there you know it's
pretty easy you can do it's just uh
k means there or just something else
this is dimension one now okay
okay this is what we get if we apply
that and in blue here you have the uh
the edges go from one
uh piece of the partition to the other
piece so it's complicated
okay so what is the problem here so this
is enough for the
that was the motivation essentially
clustering
and here the problem is uh we're
interested in knowing whether um the uh
constant the graph converges to the
trigger constant of the manifold and for
me it was intriguing because we use the
same
technology for both of them and then
we didn't know how they were related
okay so we're going to assume that the
points here so the simplest situation
really and the points x wants for xn are
a sample id inform from a domain m
in rd and again there's no there's no
not a problem with high dimensions here
so even d equals two is interesting
and uh we want to know uh the large
sample behavior of the trigger constant
of say an epsilon and bold graph okay
so it's actually work uh so this this is
the the paper that came out of that and
actually it's a even all the work uh
anyway so like i said usually i don't
present all the work like that but i
thought it would be i like to have some
feedback from this community that you
know there are a few experts here on
on the sega constant
so there's uh i'm going to present a
more recent um
another going to play i'm going to
mention more recent um
related work which i think solved the
problem uh we were looking at at that
time uh using uh more so much more
sophisticated methods that um i'm still
have to learn about but this is what we
knew about at the time
so actually misha has worked on this and
from a while back
um
and essentially this is 0.5 so the fix
is set
actually the same in this one and all
those two here so fix the set and look
at
how the discrete cut for that set
converges to uh the continuous cut
and for this one here
this is a real effort towards
trying to
see how the optimization problem on the
discrete side which really converts to
the optimization on the um
side but they they do that under some
conditions the regularity conditions on
the on the cut sets
which we also going to impose but uh in
a milder way
actually for this one we anyway um
this is also interesting work i think
those two actually are this is the long
version of the first one which is a
little confusing with conferences
conference proceedings anyway
they look at this it's interesting they
look at
the difference between uh epsilon bottle
graphs and
k-nearest number graphs in terms of
the asynthetics of the cuts but again
that's for a fixed uh set
what i'm saying about fixed set and so
on will will be uh clear as i go
in the next few slides
okay so here's the setting we have a uh
again it's not the money for but um
i think here the manifold just adds the
complexity a little bit of complications
to the problem but not um
it's not where the the money was i think
so we i think we were writing just
focusing on something a little simpler
and
in the more recent work i will mention
later really is not about manifolds or
anything else just actually using really
other tools for this which i still have
to understand myself
but anyway so let's let's look at the
bounded uh
domain so it's nice uh it's bounded it's
open
and connected
you know if you're looking at cuts we
want something that's connected and then
with smooth boundary this is not
actually not completely crucial but you
know
and um
and let's assume that the volume of m is
one uh just without loss of generality
okay
and we sample points id uniform from m
we could also sample them from uh
another density that's that's uh it
would add a little bit of complexity to
the problem but again that's not where
the difficult the real difficulty is
in my opinion
okay
and here's what does it mean by smoothie
are we going to use the notion of reach
which is uh well known for people
working that sort of area now
although
initially
yogi and collaborators used a what they
call condition numbers i don't know if
they were aware of that earlier work but
it's actually the same thing pretty much
when you don't have when when you don't
have boundaries the same thing
what is the reach of
a set so this plus here means okay this
whole thing here means that i take
uh all the uh points in our d where a
is that are within distance r of a
okay so it was sometimes called the
tubular neighborhood of a of uh i guess
i don't know if you can call it radius
but um
distance r okay
and uh
the reach of the set a is the smallest r
is the largest r such that uh when you
take a point in a tube in a tubular
neighborhood
then it has a unique projection on a
because that's the reach of the set
and actually it's shown even i mean
federer knew this in his uh really
similar paper there that he controls the
curvature for example
and but more on that it also prevents
the the set from coming too close to
each other okay
okay continue so
so okay so i used epsilon before i'm
going to use r could you draw a picture
just to help us here understand reach
so the prototypical example is the uh
the barbell that
cyan
talked about yesterday
so if you have something like this
it could be very smooth but if it comes
close here this will limit the reach
so because you know if you're within
distance okay i'm assuming
um
okay
i'm taking this as the curve not not the
inside but i'm taking this as a curve
so then if you go if you're you know if
you go let's say past this point right
here
then this points in the middle has two
projections on the on the set
okay so it's not unique anymore
so
yeah
if you take a if you take this as the
full set then you have to look at what's
you know the outside and i think he has
a decent reach and you can see that you
can roll this this condition actually
ugunto walter
your department has worked on this uh a
long time ago but on on
there's another condition called the raw
and the bo the rolling ball condition
and it's really if you can do it on both
sides it's essentially the same as
controlling the reach
yeah so
yeah
so it's a very natural notion and again
it's uh
all this work that i mentioned probably
uses something like that um
that is the work by
misha
they use essentially the same the same
thing they call it something else
okay so uh i used epsilon before 57 ball
grass i'm going to i'm going to use i'm
going to use r that's what we use in the
paper so this is the rn ball
neighborhood graph okay so i'm
connecting two points
uh that are within distance rn okay and
and this is uh the radius here depends
on n usually you want uh you know you
don't want long connectivity okay
because you are want to approximate a
manifold so um the long distances don't
uh no they don't really mean much
and
okay so
uh the trigger constant of the graph is
this we saw it before
okay so this is a discrete parameter
this is the discrete volume and uh now
the weights for us are going to be the
simple ones okay so one if the points
are within distance rn and zero
otherwise
okay
so um
if you remember i assumed that the man
the domain has volume one so the price
so this is the probability so i'm using
the uniform um distribution on m
so uh the
the
the measure of a is just the volume of a
intersection with m
and whereas so i'm defining this this is
the uh
so it's
it's it's not a probability now but it's
a measure uh of so it's the perimeter of
a so sorry the balance so the boundary
of a sorry intersection with m and then
the the volume of that but of course in
dimension uh oneness
okay
and so this is the uh
analog
to the actually i didn't define this for
the discrete k sorry so um
this is a cut and used by the set a
and a doesn't have to be within m as you
can see where it's just like
intersection with m and everything is
fine it just works just fine okay
so it's the
uh essentially the perimeter here of
you know
what's inside a
intersection with m and what's inside
and and a complement intersection with m
okay so that's the perimeter here and
then the minimum uh
we look at the minimum of the volumes
of a and a complement okay you know the
volume is the the notion that you expect
it to be okay so it's the odds of
measure k so the volume sub k here is a
k dimensionalized of measure but
normalized so that it coincides with the
bank measure
as you would expect okay
okay
so
uh okay so what is the constant of the
manifold i now realize i didn't define
it anywhere so i defined it for the
graph and for manifold you just um
define analogously with this notion of
cut right here same thing
so you know for me just starting there
like no what do we know
um
what do we know about those two
quantities we have discrete one where we
have continuous one what do we know
about them so very natural question at
least for me
and so that's that's how we got started
on this
actually coming from the for them from
the clustering uh from a clustering
application
okay so
this gets very very complicated i don't
know literature enough to have a uh
fruitful discussion with people here
really but um
you know so the apparently so there are
trigger sets and but the boundary of the
trigger set is not necessarily smooth
you know it gets comp it gets
complicated and some in some dimension
perhaps it's unknown in between
it it's it's not it's not easy okay so
thankfully we all have to reuse that but
okay see the existence of the triggers
that i don't think is that complicated
but the uh showing showing that it's not
necessarily smooth i don't think that's
easy
okay so like i said the very natural
question is
can we relate the discrete notion of
to the continuous notion of
trigger
right and again like i mean and put
myself in a setting where the comparison
would make sense right because i have a
domain
and i have points on the domain right
and the points are going to approximate
as the empirical measure is going to
approximately uniform measure on the
domain how do these you know how do
those two things uh
relate to each other okay
so unfortunately we were not able to
completely relate but i think more very
recent work
that i i was alerted to just a few
months ago
might have solved this now
so in some sense i'm going to show you
what you do when you don't have the
right tools because
i don't think it's we were using the
right tool
our approach was
it wasn't it wasn't easy and there was a
trick i'll show you later that took us a
while to figure out
but it's also somewhat elementary okay
just try to plow through and
calculations of volumes and so on and
nothing that
really if you know if you can do the
calculations and there was no real
trick except one actually later and then
but they they use other tools
okay
so now i'm going to relate the two
quantities um for a set now a continuous
set i mean actually any set with any set
of rd but in mind i have continuous sets
i have their uh
their continuous volume and then
continuous perimeter all within m okay
and then i have their continuous trigger
uh sorry the continuous uh
notion of cut
and i'm going to define the same thing
for continuous sets but uh so the
discrete analog before any sets and
particular continuous sets
would be a subset of the excise
and the continuous set would be just
anything really in rd sorry
yeah that's all i mean by that
okay so for some uh for any set a in our
d let's uh let's look so you can either
identify it but here for this talk
i don't so i just say uh sub a as the uh
in this indexes the points that are
within a okay and i'm defining the
discrete parameter here
so it has this uh you know interesting
normalization
this could be replaced by n squared
um we see it as a u statistic here you
know anyway
it could be just n squared but
this is this is a more interesting uh
normalization
we could have done of course without
normalizing it here and it will appear
later but anyway we chose to do it here
so it's just the parameter of this of
the discrete set in it induces those
discrete subsets of points it induces
okay
and this is with this we defined before
just the the the perimeter and the
discrete parameter in the graph
and this is the
so this definition of this constant uh
gamma that depends on on the m on the
dimension here okay
so this u here you can take it to be uh
the any any unit vector so it's
sometimes like the um
of the f story called cap
and
so i define the discrete parameter and
now they find this discrete volume
analogously with this particular in
particular r so what matters really here
is the r and d plus one and with this
constant here and here's our and this is
really much
somewhat easy to uh
to know to expect this normalization
this requires a little bit of thought
not that much
and uh okay so that's what it is this is
the discrete volume that
we defined earlier
applied to the
the points that defined by this set a
and an omega here omega subject will sit
later so let me make sure i explain
where it is it's the volume of the unit
sphere okay
so now that i have discrete notions of
perimeter and volume i define a discrete
notion of a cut
so the set can be anything a can be here
now anything
and then
and then this is respect the the graph
that i defined earlier the rn ball graph
on the data points okay
okay so
so here's the first theorem
and this one really is only
com you know only just you know compute
volumes and hopefully do it carefully
that's why this one doesn't really have
a trick to it
and it goes as follows so if you take
any a you know and
fixed i guess a has to be measurable
because yeah so something like
measurable and um
actually yeah
even more than that
so uh such that its boundary in m has
positive reach okay
then uh if rn goes to zero but not too
fast
so this limits the speed so it's all
more it's actually
so to have a connected graph which we
want we need r n to be log n over n to
power one over d about
and then this is uh our n has to be a
little slower than that
okay so even slower than that
so if we have that then we have this
pointwise conversion so by pointwise i
mean actually set wise conversions so if
you fix a
then you have the conversions of the
discrete
cut to the continuous cut
okay and this is a sort of result
that um
that
misha actually has in his paper
and other people in in germany um
admire van lucksburg and uh
they have um that's essentially what
they proved uh something like that
sometimes limiting uh what this set
so adding more regularity conditions on
the set a this is very mild because we
don't really
well it's somewhat mild we don't uh
impose a
lower bound on the width on the under
each so just you know
instead of the reach condition can you
just require that there is a
neighborhood of a that has a licious
retraction
just some
projection map which is the chase okay
so
okay um
it's a good question
well let's say in dimension 2 if you
have just a finite number of
points where it's not doesn't have a
positive reach then i'm pretty sure that
it works the same
but if it's like completely arbitrary
lipschitz map then i don't know
the map has to be the identity on a so
it cannot be
interested in the strong condition there
look
well let's see if i understand what
you're saying so the way i understood it
is if you take a to b a by lipset's
image of uh a unique ball something
no else
no okay
right
so we can talk offline i'll find on that
how about that
um
okay so just in our approach like i said
is fairly elementary uh the we want the
boundary here to be approachable with a
uh essentially having a tangent space
and uh it's possible it can do without
that i don't know
and
uh okay so
so immediately if you have this result
here then you have uh you also have
this uh
lower bound it's completely immediate so
this is one of the size so
essentially what we failed to prove is
the other side so this one comes
immediately from this uh pointwise or
set wise conversions
and you know
essentially okay so if you take so like
i said if you if you have a trigger set
you might not have positive reach so
just take any arbitrary set a
with a boundary having a positive reach
and then um
yeah anyway so you have uh by definition
the discrete cut so the optima this is
optimal
and this is so essentially bounce this
year
and then this here converges to uh sorry
sorry this ah
this factor should be here sorry about
that also so she had a factor here and
if i factor here just comparing those
h's here
but this is the optimal value
so minimizing this over all possible a's
essentially
so of course you have this inequality
and this part here converges to this
okay so in particular you have this and
then you mean you you just minimize over
a
okay an immunization can be over sets
with positive reach you just cannot have
a lower bound on the reach
okay
so i realize i'm
running late i'm going to go faster
so um
okay so the way we
as you can imagine and the way we
operate here is first proving some sort
of concentration for
the discrete volume
and then proving a concentration for the
discrete parameter
and the second one is a little harder
so
okay so how do we so this is the
discrete parameter the volume this is
the uh
the continuous volume
and uh we have to solve in the
consistent inequality but yet to realize
that uh we have this here so for n large
enough so we require rn to be small
enough
and that's smaller that depends on
epsilon okay so
anyway but this this is this weak
uh
down on this probability on the on the
left hand side is it was enough for our
purposes
okay and here we only require that
essentially the graph be connected
essentially for this one but for the
perimeter we required a little more
okay so you know it works as usual just
uh you know you essentially do bias
variance the composition so this would
be the bias this would be the standard
deviation in some sense
and how do you how do you control this
part right here
it's very standard you use so you
essentially you realize that
the uh discrete volume is just a u
statistic and when you realize that
we have you know we know how to control
this panel right here
and this uh
the difference between mu n and its
expectation
so that's just that
it's very classical and then um
for so i'm going to do something that
wasn't quite needed for uh
in this particular case that we're going
we will use it late we will use it later
so let's let's say that for r positive
let's call
m sub r
the points in n that are uh
away from the boundary by at least r
okay
and uh we have this limit on the
on the
bias so this here can be replaced by the
bias here
and we just have just the intersection
so if you have
so if you have uh
this is m
this is
there's a bar right here
okay
and just you know the the bias is so if
you have a say cuts right here so we're
saying is just uh
essentially the difference here would be
something like this let's say this is a
so would be something like
this would be
the the uh this would be bad the volume
here will be bound into the bias
goes to zero with r
so essentially we're in business
for the for the volume okay
it's actually easy to prove
and uh for
uh
okay and then so what i said like the
volume goes to zero you can balance in
in a more quantitative way using some
like a finite version of uh or a rough
version of whales formula for
the volume of tubular neighborhoods
so there's just a few lines uh really of
proof there
and we have something like that for the
perimeter this required a little more uh
work
but it has essentially the same flavor
and we can also express it as a use
statistic so we can you know do the same
triangle inequality and control
uh the um
the the deviations in the exactly the
same way
and for controlling devices or more
delicate requires just more computations
and we have a bound on this this is to
bound the bias again
this right here could be replaced by
the study of new n
and we have something so it's just more
complicated
okay so here's the the crucial quantity
and
the question is whether the discrete
actually converges to the continuous we
only prove one side and uh
so that's the question so we left it
open in the paper we couldn't do it
and um
i believe i understand that this paper
actually solves it at least according to
summit uh dejan
in some just conference in in june and
he said like
his work does it
and they use a notion of convergence
called gamma convergence which i wasn't
aware of before
so impulse heavier machinery and the
appropriate one i think
so
i'm going to show you what we did which
essentially is well you know what we did
you know without the the right tools i
guess then
retrospectively
and uh
okay so
i don't know what this sense is doing
here but so the issue we had was we were
just approached very elementary with the
very m we had a very elementary approach
and we tried to bounce said the
complexity of
all sets in m of course is way too large
and uh we tried you know some to
understand what how we could reduce that
complexity in some way and we just
couldn't figure it out
so we we essentially regularized the
problem we looked at so that's what
other people also did in the uh the
literature i i mentioned before but we
did it
in the milder way so we focused on cuts
so this r could be a again but um
so we focused on on cut sets that uh
have a boundary with reach at least rho
n
but now row go can go to zero that's
crucial for us to get consistency so we
were able to get an estimator for the uh
a trigger set but um anyway with a
twisted way
and
it seems like actually the straight way
of doing it works
from this recent work i just mentioned
okay so here's one of the results so
this is for the the value for the
trigger constant itself not for trigger
set
so if we have so we have stronger
conditions here so um
rn goes to zero but not too fast this is
stronger than before
and then r1 goes to zero but not too
fast also
and that depends on rn
then we have a convergence of so the uh
the minimum cut amount among that class
assets
converges to the uh up to the optimal
okay
that's what we found
almost surely
and uh okay so with the right uniform
version of concentration of the sort of
concentration equality that we had
before if we can call them that is not
really that
and uh
over that class okay so we had we had
that
and uh
so
sorry when i say that it's not uh i'm
going to it would be misleading
we were able to control the deviations
exactly the same way but um with a
little more work to make them uniform
because we needed that
and what was problematic is uh
controlling the bias
uh for the perimeter uniformity of the
class which we can't do and here is a
picture of this very easy to understand
that so i ran the corners here just to
say that you know you can have something
simple that respects those rich
conditions that we had so the big square
here is m
the little square here is r
okay
and we see that if uh
if this this so actually uh
the small the the dashed ones if the
dutch one is r so if you are you know if
you're close enough to the boundary of m
you won't see so the the discrete
parameter won't reflect the fact that
you have a perimeter right here
in the continuous side so that's why you
cannot really con that's why you can you
can't control the uh
the bias of the discrete parameter
so this this was problematic for us like
i said off we just we're turning around
and not doing the right thing then
we're able to circumvent this by
essentially focusing what on
nr as opposed to m so
essentially what's
focusing on on what was happening inside
and a little bit
and so essentially by doing that we
removed uh boundary effects but there
was a trick to it so that's the one
trick i um
yeah like i have to mention later
so um
yeah that's what i'm saying here so we
instead of looking at the the script
parameter we actually look at
sorry instead of comparing the
descriptometer with
uh
the um so instead of this without with
rn here zero okay so just m here we do
it with uh we compare the square
parameter with this okay so the predator
is the perimeter of
of r
inside the uh smaller set here okay and
when we have that when we can control we
have this control on the uh discrete
cuts and um
no and the continuous analog
okay but inside mrn
okay
and
uh okay so i think
yeah so
actually since i have them here let me
go through this so how do we prove this
theorem right here
um well you know once we have this
inequality so the convergence of the
discrete uh minimum cut over uh the the
set we're considering now to the optimal
uh to the trigger constant of the
manifold of the domain
so once we have this this requires a
little bit of work
uh
it's pretty simple then so take an er n
here so i'm i'm just going to look at
the
lower bound first
so let's take any sequence rn
in that
class of sets
and okay what is the difference between
that this cut here this cutout and
the trigger constant so do a telescopic
sum
and
this one right here is non-negative
because this one is minimum over all
possible r's
okay so this one is non-negative
and this one right here is just you know
it's just about lower bound by the
minimum over all so our n is in that
class so just a minimum for the whole
class
and this one is what it is okay so
this one the previous proposition i
showed you shows that this
is not negative in the limit
that's what this proposition is
so remains to compare this was the the
complicated part it meant
it it reminds me it remains to compare
the uh shear constant of this
the the smaller set with the trigger
comes from the larger set
intuitively there should be some
continuity and there is
so we proved something else so we
couldn't find any literature props uh
somebody here would know
it's not complicated necessarily but you
know we just uh this one this this kept
us
thinking for a while
and uh essentially that's what we get so
we have the uh constant of the smaller
set
is essentially um
that of the larger set modulo a uh an
order r term and this big o here depends
on m
okay so this is the the the
the real trick we had uh
to come up with
okay so then uh all of that uh proved we
we obtained one side of the uh
a quality we're looking for and then the
upper bounds of this other the other
equal the other side of the inequality
you can you just use the first theorem
pretty much
okay so that's that's for the
convergence of the of the discrete
uh
optimal uh value
uh over the castle sets um
we've been considering to the uh trigger
uh essentially the optimal over the
whole class of sets in the continuous
side of things
okay
um
okay so actually we can also
consistently
estimate the trigger sets um in in some
sense so
let's say take an optimizing sequence of
uh so you take r and that optimizes the
cut over the class of sets we we were
looking at
and uh if then then rn intersection with
m admits a subsequence that converges
then one and it converges any subs and
any essentially saying that any
accommodation point
so it's compact for the l1 metric and
it's any accumulation point is a trigger
set
so
this doesn't really do exactly what we
want because if you're giving so say you
can compute rn which you can't but
at least it depends on the data so it
doesn't depend on anything you you don't
know
so if you have i don't know some sort of
infinite computational power you could
perhaps come up with the rn the thing is
you don't know m right so coming up with
rn intersection with m
so okay
anyway
but we can do it so it's just uh so
okay
how do you prove something like this so
it's based on um
on the on the compactness result for the
the georgie volume and uh
and lowers me continuity also so
this uh for people in the field they
probably know about this for us it was
new but
we
were thankful to michelle pierre here
who uh
who gave us some pointers
anyway so if you form the empirical
measure based on
one of the minimizing sequences rn
then you can show that as a sequence of
measures any combination point
is essentially supported on a trigger
set so that's how you can solve it so
actually you can you can estimate the
trigger set
without knowing amp
that's yeah that's the thing so um
what i thought was an open problem i
think recently was solved by people at
cmu
and at least the last paper i showed you
which appeared uh this year
so what i said here could be uh in some
sense obsolete especially the proof
technique which is not really
informative is uh we just you know
plowed through and then didn't really
invent
interesting techniques
at all
anyway and the question that remains
past is uh is spectral clustering
consistent as finding a gut and i don't
know you know there are partial answers
out there and
i can work with misha on you know
the uh
the convergence of the uh
eigenvectors uh in the large central
limit but you know i think it remains
open so i'll be happy to discuss this uh
be up updated on this by people here
thank you
questions
so
is the
that misha did so you have like the uh
the discrete laplacian converges to the
uh
the continuous plus and right at least
you did that when uh
when the uh the neighborhood the radius
is constant do you do that also when it
goes to zero
no when it's constant it doesn't convert
it has the neighborhood radius has to go
through zero to get the convergence to
the laplace controller
if it's constant it converges to
something but it's not okay
so you let this work you prove that
right when uh when the radius goes to
zero
when they're ready
paper yeah
okay
that is under some conditions here
thank you